[Applause]
the stroke of midnight and a moment to
celebrate
freedom day in sydney queuing up phones
out they knew the rules no jab no entry
and at sydney's oldest pub the beer was
the draw oh that tastes good
i've been drinking the points
are the cans and coming back to the
point it's just so delicious
shop doors opened more than a hundred
days after they closed with eager
customers waiting to spend
i'm so glad that i can actually see
things try things on and get the right
fit rather than have the hassle of
getting at home finding out they don't
fit and bringing them back or sending
them back lockdown was pretty hard but
yeah we are now happy to return to
normal
and looking forward to it
they were looking forward to the gyms
reopening too and for some a
long-awaited workout oh look i think in
here there's so much energy so much love
to be back um yeah just nice to feel
like you got a bit of freedom back again
i'm in a gym again
the right equipment
love it and a lot of love at the barbers
a new hairdo for the state's new
premiere we will no doubt see case
numbers increase uh we will see
hospitalizations increase but we've
invested significant amounts in our
health system
we now need to learn to live alongside
the virus
70 of people in new south wales are
fully vaccinated but some australian
states are still in lockdown let's keep
going australia with the vaccination
program to all those particularly in
sydney and across new south wales today
who are opening up today um enjoy the
moment uh enjoy it with your family
enjoy with your friends
and that's exactly what they did it's
like mel gibson and brain heart you know
like
we're going we're off we're happening
it's it's all about australia and it's
all about freedom and thank you so much
no welcoming weather but this was a
bright day for sydney australia's
largest city finally back in business
laura bundock sky news